>> Sean: PRESIDENT SIPPY CUP
JOE BIDEN IS IN BELGIUM MEETING
WITH EUROPEAN LEADERS AFTER
SPENDING THE WEEKEND IN THE U.K.
WHERE HE MET WITH THE QUEEN.
ALL OF THIS COMING AHEAD OF HIS
HIGHLY ANTICIPATED MEETING WITH
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
ON WEDNESDAY BUT HE WILL NOT BE
DOING A JOINT PRESS CONFERENCE
BECAUSE IT WILL NOT BE A
COMPETITION, HE SAID.
HERE WITH REACTION TO ALL OF
THIS PLUS THE LATEST
CONTROVERSIES FOR THE ROYAL
FAMILY, EDITOR AT LARGE OF THE
DailyMail.com, GREAT PAPER,
PIERS MORGAN.
FIRST, HAVE TO DO WITH ONE
ISSUE, I WATCH THE DAY YOU WALK
OFF THE SHOW AND WE'VE HAD A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP OVER THE
YEARS AND I'M A FAN OF YOURS.
YOU HAVE THE HIGHEST RATINGS
YOU'VE EVER HAD IN THE HISTORY
OF THE SHOW AND I WANTED YOU
BACK ON NOW THAT YOU'RE MET NOT
BACK ON AIR, WHEN YOU COMING
BACK ON THE AIR?
DO YOU HAVE MORE TO DO?
>> DEFINITELY HAVING INTERESTING
CONVERSATIONS AS YOU CAN
PROBABLY IMAGINE, LOTS OF PEOPLE
WANTING THE PACE OF THE ACTION
FOR SOMEONE WHO WAS ON THAT
MORNING SHOW, THAT IS WHAT WE
DID.
IT WAS A WEIRD, SURREAL KIND OF
DAY WHERE HAVING NORMALLY YOU
WOULD GET INVITED TO A BOARD
ROOM BUT I GOT INVITED TO EITHER
APOLOGIZE TO MEGHAN MARKLE FOR
DISBELIEVING HER OR LEAVE THE
BUILDING SO I DECIDED TO LEAVE
THE BUILDING.
>> Sean: HERE'S WHAT I'D LIKE
TO UNDERSTAND.
MEGHAN AND HARRY GO ON ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PLATFORMS YOU COULD
EVER GO ON AND THAT'S
OPRAH WINFREY, THEY GIVE THIS
BOMBSHELL INTERVIEW WHERE THEY
ACCUSE WITHOUT MENTIONING BY
NAME, CLARIFIED IT WASN'T THE
QUEEN SO THAT KIND OF LEAVES
PRINCE HARRY'S BROTHER AND
FATHER HANGING OUT TO DRY AS
BEING RACIST AND YET ON THE ONE
HAND, HE IS CALLING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT FREEDOM OF
SPEECH BONKERS BUT IS WILLING TO
USE THE FIRST AMENDMENT ALONG
WITH HIS WIFE TO TRASH HIS OWN
FAMILY.
I FOUND THAT QUITE HYPOCRITICAL.
>> I THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
RIDICULOUS.
THEY WANT TO HAVE THE ROYAL CAKE
AND EAT IT, VERY HAPPY TO TRADE
OFF THEIR ROYAL TITLES, THE DUKE
AND DUCHESS OF SUSSEX WHEN IT
COMES TO NEGOTIATING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF COMPANIES
LIKE SPOTIFY AND NETFLIX BUT AT
THE SAME TIME, THEY WANT THE
RIGHT TO TRASH THE ROYAL FAMILY
AND MONARCHY AND THEREFORE THE
QUEEN ON GLOBAL TELEVISION
REPEATEDLY NOW.
THEY KEEP DOING THIS.
I THINK IT IS SICKENING TO
PEOPLE OVER HERE IN THE U.K. AND
WE'VE JUST SEEN THE QUEEN WITH
THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT A
MAGNIFICENT LADY SHE IS, BUT ON
THE THRONE FOR NEARLY SEVEN
DECADES AND IS A REMARKABLE
PERSON WHO PUTS DUTY FIRST AND
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT MEGHAN AND
HARRY DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
CONCEPT OF DUTY.
IT IS RIGHTLY HYPOCRITICAL, IT
STICKS AND PEOPLES GOAL IT'S
OVER HERE AND IN RELATION TO THE
INTERVIEW, WE'VE NOW LEARNED
THAT THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
TO BE UNTRUE, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WHAT POINT I'M ALLOWED TO NOT
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE FOR
DISBELIEVING SOMEBODY WHO WAS
POSSIBLY A LIAR.
IT IS A FARCICAL SITUATION AND
OF COURSE AS WITH ALL THESE
SITUATIONS AT THE MOMENT, THE
CANCEL CULTURE TWITTER MOB COMES
FOR YOU AND SAYS IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE MEGHAN MARKLE, YOU ARE A
RACIST WHICH I SAY I'VE NEVER
SAID A RACIST THING ABOUT
MEGHAN MARKLE OR ANYBODY ELSE,
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HER SKIN
COLOR AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
HER INABILITY TO TELL THE TRUTH
AND HER RANK HYPOCRISY AND I
THINK IT'S TIME THOSE TWO GAVE
UP THEIR TITLES, STOPPED MINING
24/7 AND LEAD BY THE BOOK OF THE
QUEEN WHOSE NICKNAME THEY'VE
HIJACKED FOR THEIR DAUGHTER,
TAKE A LITTLE TIP FROM THE
QUEEN, LESS IS MORE AND IF YOU
WANT TO BE A ROYAL, A MEMBER OF
THE ROYAL FAMILY, LESS IS MORE.
WE ARE HEARING TOO MUCH OF YOUR
YAPPING IN YOUR WHINING, IT'S
TIME TO PIPE DOWN.
>> Sean: I AM CONCERNED, MEGAN
ALSO COMPLAINED TO YOUR EMPLOYER
AND TO THE GOVERNMENT.
MY READING OF THE LAWS IN
BRITAIN, A SHOW LIKE MINE OF
WHERE I'M A TALK SHOW HOST, I DO
NEWS, STRAIGHT NEWS,
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING,
CULTURE, SPORTS, I DO IT ALL.
I WOULD HAVE PROBLEMS BEING A
BROADCASTER IN GREAT BRITAIN.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
WE ARE GOVERNMENT REGULATED AS A
REGULATORY BODY WHOSE ONLY JOB
IT IS IS TO BOSS AROUND PEOPLE
ON THE AIRWAVES AND TELL US WHAT
WE CAN AND CAN'T SAY I'M A VERY
DIFFERENT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
UNITED STATES WHERE YOU ARE
COVERED BY THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
THAT HARRY CAN'T STOMACH BECAUSE
HE ONLY WANTS THE RIGHT FOR THE
MEDIA TO SAY NICE THINGS ABOUT
HIM, NOT TO HOLD HIM TO ACCOUNT
AND IT MAKES LIKE VERY
DIFFICULT.
BUT ALSO, IT'S SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW YOU'VE DONE LOTS OF
COVERAGE ON WHICH IS THIS
EPIDEMIC OF CANCEL CULTURE WHICH
IS THIS VERY SMALL BUT VOCAL
GROUP OF ILLIBERAL LIBERALS.
I CALLED THEM THE NEW FASCISTS
WHO WANT TO TELL US HOW TO LEAD
OUR LIVES, HOW TO SPEAK, HOW TO
THINK, WHAT WE CAN ENJOY ON
TELEVISION AND MOVIES, WHAT
HISTORICAL FIGURES WE CAN
APPRECIATE AND NOT APPRECIATE
AND IF YOU DEVIATE ONE IOTA FROM
THEIR LOCAL WORLDVIEW, YOU MUST
BE SHAMED AND VILIFIED AND
CANCELED AND WE ARE SEEING IT
HAPPEN AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
CORPORATE INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO
STAND UP TO THIS NONSENSE.
I DISCOVERED AFTER I LEFT THE
MORNING SHOW OVER HERE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT MEGHAN MARKLE HAD
PERSONALLY CONTACTED MY BOSS
DEMANDING ALL SORTS OF THINGS
INCLUDING AN APOLOGY.
THAT CAN'T BE RIGHT FOR SOMEONE
LIKE MEGHAN MARKLE A PUBLIC
FIGURE TO THINK SHE HAS THE
RIGHT TO DICTATE THE FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND THE FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AND OPINION OF
BROADCASTERS LIKE ME OR INDEED
YOURSELF ON NATIONAL TELEVISION
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE'VE GOT TO
AND IT'S A PRETTY SCARY STATE OF
AFFAIRS, BUT I THINK IT IS
CERTAINLY A HILL WORTH DYING FOR
WHEN IT COMES TO PROTECTING
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
>> Sean: I WANT TO GET YOUR
PERCEPTION OF JOE BIDEN, HE HAS
THIS MEETING WITH PUTIN COMING
UP AND MY PERCEPTION IS, AND I'M
VERY OUTSPOKEN ABOUT IT, IS HE
IS WEAK, HE IS FRAIL, HE IS
STRUGGLING MIGHTILY COGNITIVELY.
I RUN TAPES OF HIM FROM 2012 AND
2016 AND TODAY, HE IS A SHELL OF
HIS FORMER SELF IN MY OPINION
AND I THINK THE TAPES SPEAK
VOLUMES.
WHAT IS THE PERCEPTION OF OUR
FRIENDS ACROSS THE POND?
>> I THINK THE PERCEPTION OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN IN HIS TRIP TO
THE U.K. WAS ALL FINE.
THIS NOISE AND CHAOS AND
UNPREDICTABILITY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP VISIT WHICH I
RATHER MISS.
BUT GETTING TOGETHER AND SAYING
BORING PLATITUDES.
I THINK THERE'S ALSO A WIDER
ISSUE ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
THAT I THINK HE SEES HIS JOB,
HIS ROLE TO CALM EVERYTHING DOWN
AS IF SOMEHOW THAT'S ENOUGH AND
I DON'T THINK IT IS.
AND WHEN DEALING WITH CHINA AND
RUSSIA, NATO, EVERY ISSUE OUT
THERE FROM THE PANDEMIC TO
CLIMATE CHANGE, I'M NOT SURE
PEOPLE WANT TO CALM AMERICA THAT
ISN'T TAKING DYNAMIC PROACTIVE
ACTION AND WHAT I DID LIKE ABOUT
HIM WAS HIS AWFUL PERSONALITY
ENABLING HIM TO CUT THROUGH THE
BUREAUCRACY AND CUT TO THE QUICK
ABOUT ISSUES AND NATO WAS A GOOD
EXAMPLE.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT MOST NATO
COUNTRIES DON'T PAY THEIR BILLS,
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP SATELLITE ON THAT
INEQUITY IN THAT IT WAS UNFAIR
THAT AMERICA SHOULD CARRY THAT
FOR SO MANY UNDERPAYING EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES.
HE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT
THAT.
HE WAS ALSO RIGHT ABOUT THE
THREAT OF CHINA GO BACK TWO OR
THREE YEARS AND JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T THINK CHINA IS A THREAT.
SUDDENLY HE DOES.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN CALLING
OUT CHINA FOR 30 YEARS TO MY
CERTAIN KNOWLEDGE SO THERE WERE
ALSO THINGS I FELT DONALD TRUMP
DIDN'T GET ENOUGH CREDIT WITH
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HE IS A
LIBERAL AND A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT
GETS TOO MUCH CREDIT FOR NOW AND
I DON'T THINK HE IS HELD TO THE
SAME ACCOUNT BY THE MEDIA IN
AMERICA THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
AND I THINK IT IS A PLAIN AND
OBVIOUS FACT AND THAT IS NOT
GOOD FOR THE U.S. MEDIA.
YOU SHOULD BE UNAFRAID TO HOLD
YOUR OWN LIBERAL DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT THE SAME ACCOUNT THAT
YOU HELD DONALD TRUMP.
OTHERWISE, YOU ARE JUST AS
BIASED AS I ALWAYS SEE THEM
SAYING FOX NEWS IS.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, THERE ARE
MORE OPINIONS BESIDE
SEAN HANNITY.
GET BACK ON THE AIR, MY HUMBLE
ADVICE TO A FRIEND, YOU WERE
BORN TO DO THIS, I SUSPECT HE
WILL BE BACK SOONER THAN YOU'RE
LETTING ON AND I HOPE THAT'S THE
CASE, YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME ON
THE SHO